hey it's us again it's Friday and it's
time for another movie retrospective
going back to the 70s yet again doing a
vampire movie we don't do a lot of those
actually doing the 1979 Verner Hertzog
adaptation of Nosferatu yeah Klaus
Kinski which is kind of like an
adaptation of Dracula yeah but so the
interesting thing about this Runner
Hertzog didn't usually do remakes I
believe this was the only one he did but
for whatever reason he had a really like
a lot of affection for the original
Nosferatu which was directed by FW
Murnau of course and came out in 1922
yeah and if you guys don't know
Nosferatu was an unlicensed copy of
Dracula right and it was it was illegal
so they they ordered it destroyed yeah
but a few copies a few copies existed
and that's the that's the nos brought to
you know that was something that escaped
the describe the describe that about
that destruction that was ordered by the
court yeah because actually Bram Stoker
was dead by the time that came out but
his widow was still alive and her name
is Florence and she um you know when
they made Nosferatu when Murnau made
Nosferatu he's like well we can use like
the Dracula story but we'll just change
everybody's names yeah change a couple
things and no one will be the wiser yeah
because it wasn't in public domain
except nobody so he got sued and like
they did order you know all the copies
destroyed but luckily that didn't happen
because that's actually you know a
classic of silent cinema yes so this is
like a reboot or remake of the band copy
right that'd be a good way to put it
yeah of the counterfeit Dracula yeah and
it had its own qualities I'll tell you
what that that's for the vampire from
nostril rot too had an awesome look yeah
you know it look good and so you know
more like described in the book I feel
like because you know because the Bela
Lugosi one was so iconic I think a lot
of people like ice it seemed like a lot
of vampire movies like
went to that we're like oh you know
Dracula he's like a foxy aristocrat type
dude yeah but in the book they actually
described him much as he looked in the
original Nosferatu when he was count
warlock and much like Dracula looks in
Verner Hertzog's version which came out
in 1979 he looked like a rat like a ran
like a rat person yeah and that lines up
more with vampire each Eastern European
vampire traditions these weren't sex
symbols they were something that crawled
out of a crypt yeah they were yucky and
smelly and they had like you know in a
pair and this one too like you know the
one that Verna Hertzog made he really
does make he plays a lot on the plague
theme you know there's 11,000 rats in
this you know sort of you know what I
mean so he really plays on that here
comes the plague on our shores and it's
like you know as and him as a living
plague type of thing and they made him
very look very rat like because yeah
that and that was one of the reasons why
I like Salem's Lot because in seeing
them as a lot they used the nostril it
was a damn monster yeah and Klaus cut
does a really good job in this movie
because he's not some kind of verbose
you know aristocratic you know nobleman
you know when he speaks and this is just
a pitiful nasty little sucker you know
yeah and you know go with the pig the
rats were follow just stuff like that
he's just nasty in he yeah he's like
super creepy and is a beautiful he's
yeah he's pitiful he's like he's sort of
sympathetic because he has a
conversation with Harker kind of early
on in the film about how about the
burden of immortality's a you know of
not being able to die yeah and so like I
said they made him a slightly more
sympathetic he's still not that
sympathetic I mean obviously he's still
a monster he's in suffering but he's
yeah he'd they make him more of like a
suffering character which like I said
that's kind of a baby he's a car he's
thirsty he's an asset all right yeah
so the interesting thing about this and
I and I feel like this is something that
I find really really interesting because
I read you know Bram Stoker's novel and
as most people have I said I assume I'm
always interested in how they change
[ __ ] up you know what I mean
now nas brought to you obviously they
had to change
some details about its they didn't get
sued even though that didn't work what
burner Hertzog did he sort of took the
book and the original Nosferatu and then
like he combined those two things but
then he kind of like went off on his own
direction like the setup of the story is
pretty much the same it's like Jonathan
Harker is going to Transylvania
you know Count Dracula is gonna buy some
land and he's a you know a real estate
guy's solicitor or whatever and he has
to go there and he gets trapped in the
castle and whatnot now the interesting
thing and this happened in the original
Nosferatu - in the 1922 one was actually
set I believe in vismara Germany or
Bremen this one is also supposed to be
said in vismara Germany because the
original one was except the town
officials of bismarck Verner Hertzog
shoot there so actually most of the
stuff that's supposed to be Germany is
actually Delft in the Netherlands and
all this stuff at Dracula's castle that
is an actual castle and it's in
Czechoslovakia yeah look at the movies
really good it's a beautiful beautiful
mess especially for such a low-budget
movie yeah I think they spent much money
on 1.4 million yeah not much and maybe
that was actually not too bad for the
70s though well yeah
but especially for a European production
you know but it was just kind of a cheap
movie but it didn't really matter
because it was executed pretty well and
everything's different like you know
when Dracula or nos prof. - arrives at
the port it's not a night in some scary
port or anything it's broad daylight
yeah and he just kind of rolls on up
everything in the canal things don't
look epic they look kind of mundane and
realistic like that's what really looked
like it would really look like that you
know so that was the one thing I kind of
give the movie credit for it's not
overreaching or over playing things in
being theatrical kind of downplaying a
lot of stuff yeah almost the opposite
like I said it you know obviously Klaus
Kinski
as Count Dracula looks really creepy and
really otherworldly like he comes off
very very alien like a little lab I know
right I mean it's Klaus Kinski yeah he's
an insane person yeah but what's great
is that with that that scene where he
asks how far away it is this property
that he bought and the guy says well you
know what do you say it took me a month
four weeks or four weeks by horse and he
just went oh but it's far he said on
land it's far so he's like I'm making a
[ __ ] right yeah and it's just it's just
kind of funny because you never see any
depictions of a vampire kind of being
frightened by the distance yeah a good
touch like oh that's kind of problematic
when you're a vampire yes basically what
he's thinking and you know probably he
hasn't left his castle yeah here's an
atomic long time in OS is a big journey
yeah he was just I'm assuming that he's
like well the thing about it is that you
know obviously in the original novel
Dracula was like I guess he was like
running out of peasants like about were
around so he said I'm gonna move to
London so there's like millions and
millions of people that I can eat um
this one kind of went in the same
direction as kind of the later like the
Francis Ford Coppola one and stuff like
that where he becomes obsessed with Lucy
now here's the thing that I was gonna
say about how I'm interested in how they
change [ __ ] up all the time and
interestingly in 1979 there was a lot of
vampire or Dracula adaptations that came
out that year and afterward because that
was the year that it went into the
public domain so you could do without
having to pay anybody because also 1979
they had that one I think John Badham
directed it Frank Langella played the
count and weirdly they did the same
thing that this movie did they switched
the characters of Lucy and Mina for I
don't know why it didn't like make it
and also I think they made van Helsing
Mina's dad or something like that but
this one what they did Lucy is the main
character like the main woman and that's
Jonathan's wife Mina is in it but she's
in it for like maybe two seconds she's
like in one scene like his Lucy's friend
something like that so she is not the
main character she does not feature in
it um Van Helsing is also a very very
minor role yeah he basically just shows
up is like yeah it's a vampire and we
can't do anything about it or I don't
even believe it's a vampire what
happened he's not given kind of like a
heroic final scenes where he defeats
Dracula it doesn't really go down like
that matter of fact the way Dracula is
destroyed in this vamp is very different
actually the way Nosferatu is destroyed
is very different from what you see the
bells the Bela Lugosi Dracula how he
went down it was it's a totally
different story
yeah it really goes in a different
direction like I said the character of
Lucy who is played by Isabella Johnny
the French actress and who is actually
was a perfect choice for this because
the way that her character is because
her character is supposed to be like
purity personified because she's like
the only one that can defeat the monster
and all this other stuff so Isabella
Johnny you know if you've ever seen her
in any other movie she was in the
Tennant she was in possession I believe
she's like so beautiful that she doesn't
look like a real person she's like very
she's very ethereal looking and they
made her look particularly ethereal in
this movie she's very pale she looks
like you know she's got those big eyes
and she has like that really dark hair
and she just looks like perfect and
front like porcelain that's the girl
from the tenant yeah she was with the
big seventies glasses yeah she looks
more normal in that but in this gym
she's very was really good-looking and
that almost too good-looking that's what
I mean she eerily yeah I'm about some of
the bottom profile the way the nose and
the upper lip the way it meets on her it
just she's got a nose mouth arrangement
that just kind of a nose mouth
arrangement that's very conducive to the
I yeah I've always thought she was like
one of the most beautiful women ever
that's ever lived yeah it's not her eyes
though I don't think I think it's her
nose in her mouth yeah I'm good about
the way that sits on her skull when you
see her you'll you'll see what I'm
talking about but she really the itch
but yes so what they do with this like I
said the beginning of it is very similar
to the novel and very similar to other
Dracula adaptations you know where
Harker goes that there's the thing with
Renfield and he's
like gone crazy and they put him in an
asylum and he just laughs all the time
and tries to eat flies and whatnot yeah
um you know Harker goes there
Dracula feeds on him no three weird
sisters in this like no the vampire
ladies who are not in this Harker is in
the castle and he's basically a prisoner
of the castle dracula's kind of like
snacking on him and stuff yeah and then
you know Dracula is like oh there's Lucy
and that's the you know the property
that I'm buying is right down the street
from her so I'm gonna go get that so he
just basically leaves Jonathan in there
and like a in a drained State and he
takes off in the middle of the night
with all his coffins and like I said and
he rolls up and what's supposed to be
Bismarck Germany but is actually Delft
and kind of rolls in with all his
coffins and his rats and everything
right
yeah don't spoil too much the moon I
won't like I said the ending is very
very different
um so I'm just warning you right now it
doesn't end the same way the movie the
strong side of the movie is this you see
this movie to see Klaus Kinski do drag
do not spur onto his version of a
vampire is quite good I like it it's
very DET dude with like born you play
yeah good I would say probably the weak
the weak part of the movie is that it
had I thought it had kind of a humdrum
or subpar Renfield although I'm saying
this because it's really hard to beat
Tom Waits as Renfield
he was Tom Waits is really yeah this guy
Renfield only in probably like three
scenes
yeah and he's just kind of like I didn't
really I didn't really care for it and
it should be that that guy is not an
actor he's actually a waiter he's a
writer I was gonna say that I thought he
was something out of maybe like a
low-budget community theater yeah I
damned weights nailed it
he really did he nailed that role I mean
all roll all Renfield should be compared
to Tom Waits yeah I really that's and
there's like the Coppola Dracula had
like a lot of things I didn't like about
it like in casting issues
no but uh since we're terrible yeah it's
like get British people or don't don't
get American people that are trying to
do an owner just miscast so and I love
what a new writers just that's that's
not they're not that was not their money
it was it was just kind of like if you
guys saw um Dangerous Liaisons the one
with Glenn Close in it they put Keanu
Reeves in that too and he was just as
out of place he just he's from
California right it's like he you can
tell he's from Kent and no dig on him
he's a good actor like I've seen him in
other movies but they just insisted
first for whatever reason for some pure
rock Sophos they kept putting him in
these movies we just really did not
belong yeah that's just not in his
wheelhouse right you know he's not good
at playing aristocrats he's not good at
playing period pieces you know what I
mean but it's like you know put him in
an action movie put him in like a teen
comedy put him into what that he's great
but I by yeah like I said it's no ding
on him it's just people have specialties
and and that's not his but um but yeah
so yeah the Renfield in this was kind of
like I said he's not an actor he just
basically giggled all the time which
some people liked I guess like according
to the reviews every top Tom Waits
though but like yeah you can't got to it
the way he delivered that character just
slam dunk yeah yeah and but you know the
thing about this one though it's like
I'm not even sure that I would call
Verna Hertzog's Nosferatu a horror movie
it's almost kind of like I don't know
what I would call it exactly it's like
yes it's based on Dracula yes it has
horrific elements but so much of it is
about the visuals of it I mean it's a
gorgeous gorgeous movie it's just very
it's very ponderous it's almost like
I've seen it compared to like a poem
like about suffering and about plague
and about things like that it does
really have that impression - it's like
it's very languid but it but it works
though really and it actually when it
came out it actually got really really
good reviews and it still gets good
reviews today I mean I think I looked on
Rotten Tomatoes or whatever and it's got
like 94% or something so it's something
that I'll tell you what though it did
not really have a lot of the track
the tropes that you see over right it is
its own thing yeah and like I said it's
uh it's probably the most different
adaptation oh yeah
Dracula that I've seen in the sense that
you know what I mean when you see like
the Frank bat or the Frank Langella one
yeah they switch the characters and yeah
they did this and that yeah and a lot of
them and a lot of them leave out a lot
of characters like a lot of them will
leave out like Quincey Morris for
example you know and [ __ ] like that but
you know this one kind of just went in a
completely different direction and the
ending is completely different yeah and
it's not kind of like oh we're gonna all
team up and you know kill this this
thing that's come into the town it's
just it doesn't really go down that way
almost more like a I don't know what I
call here's another here's here's
another angle I'd like to come at it
this way don't expect a modern really
fast paced movie expect them expect a
movie of the 70s trying to deliver you
what a silent movie delivered it's you
know that it has kind of kind of has the
tempo of a silent movie but that's not
silent it really does it's it's like
that and that's because that's what the
source material was yeah so it's not do
not expect a modern Dracula yeah movie
like like Bela Lugosi's no no not really
matter of fact you know the source
material the book is you know the Bram
Stoker book is not modern no it's
written not it is kind of hotter it's
ponderous so this movie does does kind
of call back to that it is along that
line it's not a it's not a modern movie
yeah and like I said I don't even know
if I'd call it a horror movie it's a
gothic movie yes sir
um but I don't think I'd call it a
horror movie but yeah the interesting
thing and like I said Verner Hertzog I
did not make remakes because he liked to
do his own movies but this was his he
thought this was the best German
language film ever made and he wanted to
pay homage to it now some of the shots
in his version are exactly the same shot
as we're in Murnau's version but he
specifically said he wanted to take in a
new direction he said I always wanted to
bridge
you know the Germanic film from back
then you know the German expressionist
kind of movement with the modern era
what was at the time the modern era and
then he's like then I felt I could go on
into the future with whatever films I
wanted to make because I had bridged
this gap in German film it's a
good-looking film when I saw it I
thought it was a 80s and she doesn't
know this yes 1979 production but I
thought it was more like 85 yeah you
know look good interesting thing too is
that when they filmed this I mean most
of the in the United States and we saw
it on shutter you're gonna see the
english-language version one what they
did was they filmed two versions of it
simultaneously they filmed one where
everyone was speaking English and they
filmed one where everyone was speaking
German now Verna Hertzog obviously he's
German so he prefers the German language
version he thinks it's more authentic
I'm not real sure how different it is
like all the shots are pretty much
identical like I said they filmed them
at the same time they would just film
one scene in English and then they would
film the same scene again in German so
you know I don't know how much
difference there is between the two I've
never seen the German language version
evidently if you get the blu-ray it has
both versions on it yeah that'd be good
but yeah I would I'm actually curious to
see the German language version just to
see how much difference there is because
you know in my opinion you see this
movie to see Klaus Kinski's
interpretation of what an Oscar ought to
what he was like yeah he pretty much he
pretty much nailed it he's a creepy old
man kind of afraid to leave the house
yeah creepy and just some of the shot
some of the shots of him like the whole
screen is black but then just yeah like
little in the middle of screen it's like
so so creepy he's got this purse that he
can't really manage and he can't die and
he's got this blood thirst and he's
[ __ ] miserable he's like a living
ghost really when you see him he's not
like a living man he's he's like a ghost
yeah just the physicality of plays it is
really really good like it I loved the
scene where you know
yeah well I loved the scene like and
when the ship rolled up in the canal
like he didn't get out in the day
obviously because he's a vampire but
like after everybody had gone to bed and
he's like creeping out of the thing with
his coffin under his arm and [ __ ] like
that is yeah the shadow isn't [ __ ] like
that may be centuries old he just says
some like meant mundane little comments
and stuff from now and then you're just
like it's just [ __ ] creepy yeah
really
yeah if you were a parasite yeah and
actually if you're interested in not
Sprott - and in the original Nosferatu
if you haven't seen it I recommend
watching shadow of the vampire which is
sort of a fictionalized account of the
making of FW Murnau's Nosferatu in 1922
and it's just it's really really funny
like the whole it's kind of a black
comedy but not quite the whole premise
of it is that Max Schreck who played
count warlock in the original das brot -
was for real a vampire well in like
that's how that's how hardcore Murnau
was he's like I went out and found an
actual [ __ ] vampire to put my movie
just murder you know verisimilitude so
uh but yeah it's it's actually really
good maybe it was on Netflix or shudder
for a while I don't know if it's still
on there anymore but if you haven't seen
it I would recommend that - if you're
interested in dracula adaptations so i
guess that'll do it for our discussion
of 1979's
Nosferatu directed by Verner Hertzog so
hope you guys enjoyed it remember if you
like the show - like share subscribe on
all your social media share with all
your friends and family if you'd like to
financially support the show you can go
to our patreon page at patreon.com slash
13 o'clock podcast or you can go to our
blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account if you'd
like to give a one-time donation
remember our regular episodes of 13
o'clock come out every Tuesday these
movie retrospectives right here come out
every Friday and we also have 13 o'clock
matinee which is three new movies in the
theater that comes out on Sunday so we
will see you next time bye